-Our next guest serves as
national political correspondent
for NBC News and MSNBC.
He also hosts MSNBC's newest
original podcast
"The Revolution with
Steve Kornacki,"
which is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Steve Kornacki,
everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll just jump in.
I'll ask the question everyone
would want me to ask.
How much sleep have you had?
-80 minutes.
-An 80-minute nap.
When did the 80-minute nap
take place?
-About an hour
before I came over here.
If I'm a little groggy,
I apologize.
-So you know, you have
a reputation, a well-earned one,
of being able to process this
data as it's coming in
in real time and helping explain
it to those of us
who are laymen watching at home.
Do you ever worry about how fast
it's going to come in,
or at this point,
does adrenaline kick in
and you know you can do it?
-No, no, it's constant fear
and panic.
It reminds me of studying
for a test or something.
And it's just like --
As I was telling people
before the election,
I'm the only person in America
who wishes we had another month
of the campaign
because I needed the prep time
to get ready for it.
-Can you put last night --
And again, obviously the grain
of salt, nothing really has been
decided as far as
who's controlling
the two chambers.
But historical context,
this does seem like a pretty
good night for Democrats.
-I mean, the fact that a day
later we're sitting here saying
we don't know yet officially
who's going to
control the House,
we don't know who's going to
control the Senate --
the Democrats certainly have
a chance,
a path to controlling
the Senate --
that in and of itself I think is
just an achievement for them,
relative to how these midterm
elections have gone in the past,
especially when
the sitting president has
the approval rating
that Joe Biden has.
Because you look at the
presidents in the past who have
had good midterms
and they've had like
65%, 70% approval ratings.
Joe Biden is sitting at 44%.
So I think that's the thing that
caught people off guard
was you look at Biden, you look
at his popularity,
you look at the attitudes about
the economy,
you're just expecting his party
to kind of take it on the chin.
And whatever happens,
they may lose the House still,
they may end up losing 10, 15
seats or something,
but that's not historically
taking on it the chin.
-So it did seem like a
repudiation of Donald Trump.
Right? He picked a lot of
candidates and the Republicans
who distanced themselves more
from Trump,
certainly Ron DeSantis in
Florida, I feel like that's what
you're going to be seeing Fox
News crowing about
over the next couple of days.
They're going move the narrative
over to that.
Do you think Donald Trump
continues to be sort of
an anchor to
the Republican Party
taking back a large majority?
-I really wonder what's going to
happen now
because he literally, on
the morning of the election, was
teasing this idea of
a November 15th announcement
that he's running again in 2024.
I'm really curious after this.
Is he going to follow through
with that now?
Are there folks around him
telling him,
"Hey, maybe back off
for a little bit here"?
And it does seem like there have
been a bunch of moments
since 2015 when Donald Trump
first emerged
where you kind of wondered is
this the moment when sort of
the Republican establishment,
whatever you want to call it,
can kind of coalesce
around a different path?
Because a lot of them want to
and have kind of, you know,
for various reasons have not
done it.
And you wonder if DeSantis
winning so decisively
in Florida, with Trump going
after him,
now there's clearly separation
between the two of them.
For that matter in Georgia with
Brian Kemp, the governor there.
Trump came after him in the
primary earlier this year.
Kemp survived that primary
easily.
He won last night easily
in Georgia.
Is there sort of a coalition
that's kind of emerging there
that could move the Republican
Party in a different direction?
I don't know, though.
That question's been raised many
times since 2015.
The answer's been no every time.
-Exit polling, is it still
too early to tell
or do you think we can say that
abortion was a bigger issue
than maybe in the weeks leading
up to it we thought it would be?
-Yeah, I'm kind of two minds.
I think it definitely
could have been.
I think it definitely could have
motivated a lot of Democrats,
who as I say, didn't think
Joe Biden --
didn't think the world of
Joe Biden to vote anyway.
I tend to think
the Trump factor, though,
was big in this thing 'cause
you can look at Republicans
who had success. You talk about
DeSantis in Florida.
DeSantis is pro-life,
so it didn't affect him.
It didn't keep him from doing
incredibly well in Florida.
I think where you saw the real
separation between Republicans,
a place like Georgia.
Herschel Walker, Brian Kemp.
They're both pro-life.
But Herschel Walker is the one
who's underperforming
considerably here
and I think the Trump factor has
a lot to do with that.
-And I guess candidates matter,
right?
I think that we talk a lot about
how divided the country is
and how people tend to vote
along party lines.
But certainly, when you put Kemp
against Herschel Walker,
for example, that's the same
state, and you can tell
that's really just an issue of
candidates, wouldn't you say?
-Yeah. Look.
There's a voter in Georgia,
and in Georgia it's really
in the Atlanta suburbs, who is
not nuts about Joe Biden,
really doesn't like
the Democratic Party,
but really doesn't like
Donald Trump.
And Kemp checks every box
for them
because Kemp isn't a Democrat,
he's a conservative,
but he also vouched for the 2020
election in Georgia.
Trump said, "Well, that's it.
That disqualifies you
as governor.
I'm sending in somebody to run
against you in the primary."
And Kemp stood his ground
and won the primary.
And to that voter,
Kemp suddenly became
a very attractive candidate.
Somebody like Herschel Walker,
who's much more closely aligned
with Donald Trump, it doesn't
have that kind of a story.
You could see these big
Republican counties sort of
on the outskirts of the Atlanta
metro area,
it was really striking.
You're seeing these 7-, 8-point
differences
between where Kemp is running
and where Walker is running
last night.
-How far could I zoom in on
a district without you knowing
what district it was
on one of those maps?
[ Laughter ]
-Is this the setup
for a test here?
-No, it's not.
If I just showed you the lines
of a county,
you'd be like,
"I know where that is."
-There's 3,100 of them. Trust
me, a lot of them look similar.
[ Laughter ]
-You have this podcast,
"The Revolution."
This is about Newt Gingrich.
This is about 1994.
Was this something that has
fascinated you for a long time?
-Yeah, I mean, '94 was one of
the first elections, you know --
Believe it or not, I was kind of
into this stuff as a kid.
[ Laughter ]
So '94 was kind of
a formative one for me.
But it was a big deal because I
just remember the Democrats had
controlled Congress,
they controlled the House
for 40 straight years
heading into '94.
And I remember my introduction
to politics was that it was just
the idea of Republicans
controlling Congress
was just unthinkable.
In '94, all of a sudden,
it happens.
And as I look back -- It's
a point of reference for me,
but as I look back over the last
generation, I really think
it was the starting point of
where we are today,
which is politics really is
this nationalized thing.
I grew up in Massachusetts.
Tip O'Neill, when I was a kid,
was a towering political figure.
He was the Speaker of the House
in the 1980s.
He had this saying,
"All politics is local."
And everyone would just repeat
that as if it was --
This was the high understanding
in politics.
It's not anymore.
It's almost all national now.
People, Democrat, Republican,
red, blue,
they follow national stories,
national characters,
they're motivated by national
issues, national storylines.
I think '94 was really the first
nationalized midterm election.
And it's really kind of grown
into what it is today.
-You mentioned
you were interested
in this at a young age.
By the way, everybody laughed.
I think they believe you.
But --
[ Laughter ]
I also want to point out, you
have brought video evidence.
This is local-access television?
-Somebody dug this up. Yeah.
My high school in Massachusetts,
there were two kids.
They hosted a comedy show.
-Yeah.
-On the public-access channel,
which was in the basement of
our high school.
And they asked me to sit down
and just do commentary on --
I think it was the '94 election.
And I realized when they aired
it, they thought --
I was playing it straight.
But they figured it was so
boring, it would be funny.
[ Laughter ]
-I should note --
When you go back and you watch
people from high school,
it's always fascinating to see
how they turned out.
You have been the straightest
line of anybody I've ever seen
from who you were last night
to who you are here.
Take a look.
-As mandated by
the Constitution, 33 seats
or one-third of the Senate will
be up for re-election in 1994.
Since it would be impractical
for me to go over each race,
I'll only go over a few of
the highlights this year.
The Senate balance is 56-44 for
the Democrats as of this moment.
It is highly plausible that
the Republicans could take over
the Senate for the first time
since 1986.
That's all for now.
There's other races.
Perhaps another time,
I'll talk about more.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I just wish -- I wish it ended
with like, "And one day,
I'm going to have a giant map
and I'm going to be able to
zoom in on that map."
Hey, it was really --
I mean this from the bottom of
my heart.
Every time I go through this,
it's really lovely to have you
sort of leading the way.
Thanks so much for making time
for us
when you've had 80 minutes of
sleep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really appreciate it.
Steve Kornacki, everybody.
All six episodes of his podcast
"The Revolution" available now.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."